so this is one of those films being
honest that I cannot believe got made it
is comedy it's sci-fi it's horror it's
mental and it's you know it I love I I
love that this got made can you sort of
talk about the fact that this is a genre
busting not what you're expecting kind
of movie well I haven't seen it
tonight's the first time I will see it
and but I think that doesn't really
matter right I mean you have to see it
to believe it but I from what I've heard
too the way Larry um used you know like
he breaks the fourth wall line and stuff
like that I I love that I think
that's well I think it's a yeah it's a
movie that you really do want to see
with a group of people in a
theater which is
nice you know that communal experience
because you you wouldn't want to sit
home alone alone and watch this by
yourself um and uh so because it's
really sort of built that way
um yeah I I think that it was you know I
was certainly trepidacious uh after I
read it and I thought it was funny but I
didn't know whether I wanted to do it
and then um and then you know when they
said Larry Charles was doing it and we
had a couple of Zoom meetings and I was
I was a longtime fan of his and his work
and and um I thought that was really
interesting that he wanted to do it and
then he got what these guys were trying
to do and then um then I still wasn't
sure and so I said I need to I need I
can't agree to this until I meet the two
guys we have I'll have dinner with them
and then of course I fell in love with
them and you know we spent 4 hours
together and um so you know there there
in in a in a in a world in a world of
you know insane political correctness
and you know Banning of books and don't
say this don't say gay don't do that you
better not TR you better not do
that this was sort of refreshing and and
I love their their their their audacity
and and just they don't really give a
crap whether you like it or not it's you
know this
they're this is them having fun with a a
particular genre and um and obviously
they had done it for audiences the two
of them there was a Twan show at Upright
Citizens Brigade so they sort of knew
how it worked for an audience and then
but it's a very different thing of being
in a 200 seat theater preaching to the
converted and then to put it on a big
screen and and actually see sewer boys
in a cage it's also hard hard to make a
movie that is different that just breaks
out of the usual yeah you know the usual
norms and the way films are structured
and what's okay and what's not okay I
mean it's it's nice that there's
something different and funny and listen
I I I really mean this sincerely you two
are both fantastic in this uh but I do
think it helped that you had the sewer
uh boys to work with do you yeah I I do
I think they added a lot especially they
guard nature of their performance you
know you know the sewer
boys first of all to find two sewer boys
is the casting of that it was it was not
since Scarlet ohhio the search for
scarlet Ohara the search for the sewer
boys went on for months and months and
finally because you know the the problem
was we were looking for sewer boys with
Tails right and uh it's hard to find
that you can find sewer boys but they
don't usually have tails you had a kind
of a LoveHate relationship with the
sewer boys well you didn't really have
to work with them well I did I did one
you know backpack and Whisper that's
their names that's their real names the
two the the real sewer boys who played
the sewer boys they they were called
backpack and Whisper right I want to say
that you did all your stuff with the
super boards right so we were shooting
it was the like the last day of shooting
last night
and you have the scene where well I
don't want to like okay spoiler alert um
I he has a scene where he says goodbye
to the Sewer boys we were all crying I
mean it was so good it was it was
beautiful thank you it was thank you I
want to ask you specifically about uh
having to feed them and the way you feed
them have you seen the movie mhm with
the uh spitting of I I was uh rolling it
really was yeah no he feeds them like a
a mother bird he he chews up it's they
eat deli meat they like ham and I chew
it up and then spit it into their mouths
and they're in a cage you know so um so
it's not like me I had asked Larry if I
could you know get stand over them and
have them underneath here like a motherb
bird but he said no they can't
move they don't do too much the super
boys they they it's extra that costs
extra to get them to move a lot they can
do this a lot but um so he said no I
want you to actually spit into their
mouths from out you know outside the
cage so I you know I said okay that's um
something and um they had did have one
the mouth could move on one of them I
think at least they showed me that maybe
it was just for close subs or something
but his little mouth and little teeth
could move up and down but um that was
thousands of dollars and uh um yeah look
it's it's a it's a you know it's a it's
a movie about ultimately it's a movie
about family it's about people trying to
create a family as weird as they all are
and they are all truly bizarre people
they want a family I mean he's even
though he gave up one of his
sons and just raised one of them because
they had separated and she raised the
other he found himself you're raising
two sewer boys you know to replace that
in his life and uh and so it's sort of
it is sort of moving in its strange way
that um he cares so deeply about them
they're like rescue dogs you know I got
to go but I really can't wait for your
reaction to this movie because it's
going to be interesting excited oh she's
great in it she's hilarious you're both
fantastic in it for real thank real I
got to
go